jason jackson he covers the miami heat
and
miami heat with a big win last night
with my guy jimmy butler
was great in the fourth quarter he had
40 points including 15 in that
dominating fourth quarter
and they take game one from uh milwaukee
jay jacks good to talk to you again
you know i've talked about pat riley
with what he's done uh with this team
building it
i i think that eric spoelstra is going
to be a hall of famer when it's all said
and done
tyler hero comes from kentucky duncan
robinson from
division three to michigan and now
becoming one of the better
shooters in the game but pat riley has
done a
brilliant job building this team how
would you explain it
i'll tell you two quick stories about
each that are super cool check camera
who
is the uh right now he's like scout
emeritus but he's been with
pat uh a high-level executive with the
heat uh for
the majority of if not all of these 25
years with the heat
and he went and saw a workout in
michigan uh
for for robinson and the majority of it
was shooting obviously and and
i believe he didn't even get to his car
before he was
in spo's ear like we have got to get
this kid like this was
one of the most amazing shooting
performances
i have ever seen that chet had seen
everybody all right he saw everybody
back to where guys were dribbling with
one hand behind their back and so uh the
fact
that the heat are willing to go that
deep
uh and find the guy that's not even
drafted that that's
no one's really clamoring for and to
duncan's credit
he bought in did the summer league route
got to the g league team got the two-way
deal
came in the camp this year hoping for a
rotation gig
ends up starting as for tyler hero
listen he was blue chip he was
you know made all of wisconsin cry when
he decided to go to kentucky
and it was great his first year i do
some fundraising for coach cal you know
back when he would
join us back in the espn days came
friendly and and each summer
i go to lexington but uh that summer i
guess it would have been two summers ago
uh kentucky had their international trip
in the bahamas so we went
and i remember calling back to my boys
justin and jordan because they follow
all these high school phenoms
i'm like who is this kid from wisconsin
uh and i rolled the r because i've been
in miami so long who's this henro
here in the bahamas my son jordan goes
dad it's
it's hero and that dude can ball and i
mean he was in this gym dance
and i mean against national teams
bouncing all over the place
dunking on dudes the flare and
and the pizzazz he carried through it's
been a
long long time since i've seen a rookie
have so little concern about what he did
not know
and just went out and played basketball
it's amazing to watch he's a jason
jackson miami heat
tv host joining us on the program and we
worked together at the mother ship a
long time ago
you remember your first sports center uh
i do
and it was an accident somebody called
in sick i can't remember who
was it big show bob stevens who called
out no
that bob was not there yet okay okay all
right that is phenomenal shout out
uh no i was on uh with
it was a six o'clock sports center
because you know when you first come in
they make you
sit for two weeks and watch sportscenter
yeah you know
and you're just watching television did
you enjoy watching me
i i always did but again this was the
six
the 6 30 edition or six o'clock at that
point and uh
it was uh susie calver um yours truly
and
and bob lee ooh and i was over on that
side set so they only had me on i
believe like
twice in the whole hour uh but as you
remember
sitting down that first time first of
all you're like why am i here and please
don't bleep up
that's fine i did that for a year at 2
30 though a lot of bleeping up for a
year yeah
uh thank god for espn news got me a lot
of reps for a year
and uh and and people like yourself and
and you know who like on the set was
really really
key to me just that getting my feet
solid on the ground
uh each night was actually craig kilmore
and it's funny a lot of people could see
him as
maybe not the best teammate or worried
about his stardom over there
and they would be correct jason what for
you
for you because coming to the big show
babe everybody's trying to
throw their biggest punches just hang
with you how did killborn help you
but he was like just it just in
condensing the idea of
sitting there the enormity of it of the
simplicity of how to get stuff done
obviously stuart and scott and i were
extremely close and i got a lot of shots
before a lot of the espn2
uh folks did and that that did not go
well for a lot of people but
now jason jason had a cubicle outside of
my office
oh you're being your secretary you were
yeah you would have been my secretary
but one day i decided that i wanted to
put another tv monitor in my office
because i was
doing all these blind highlights the 11
o'clock sports center
i didn't get to i wanted to see more
games while i'm writing the show
so management wouldn't give me another
tv monitor
so i went out and i stole jason's
and he came in that day and he goes
where is my monitor
you've seen my tv i've got it in there
in my office with my door
shut and i'll be i i was like let's find
that let's you know
let's find it by the way a little tiny
mod
[Laughter]
oh i don't know if i ever told you that
i stole your monitor but oh i was
i i was sherlock holmes i was gonna find
that monitor
i don't know who has it but the statute
of limitations is over with that let's
call engineering and get this kid
another monitor
this is ridiculous what kind of buzz do
we have on south beach for tua tonga
vialoa
oh my goodness well thank goodness uh
there's a curfew over there
because it it can get buzzy as you well
know
uh listen uh the joy of
just having something that
is i want to be respectful of everyone
in between
mourinho and this young professional
professional quarterbacks that have been
a long way
uh but uh it bless his heart
uh ryan fitzpatrick's mother passed and
so he was
away for this first scrimmage and and
the dolphins i don't quite get the
marketing
aspect of this but they didn't allow any
video from
from their first scrimmage and obviously
no fans were there but
a lot of buzz about the young fella he
obviously can sling it he's got a great
personality he's embraced this place uh
dan you know the deal
uh w's like there is it's funny about
this place
uh it's been a long time since the the
dolphins have been
expectant of w's uh but the the thing
that will change on a dime
in this town the team i work for has
been winning consistently
for the whole time i've been here i'm
about to wrap up my 16th season with the
heat
uh but the second and i think it's only
happened once uh in my time the second
the dolphins
uh were in the playoffs everybody went
oh nice job heat
and they're gone right right right to
all things dolphins and so
all it's gonna take is this young fella
under center
getting some wins and an idea of the
possibility of the postseason
and everybody's going to go nuts but
he's that the one thing about this place
is this
as you know dan there's plenty to do so
you better grab people's attention
and the only way to do it in miami is
with winning what do you miss about
covering lebron
uh that's a really good question i i so
enjoyed it
i wanted to show bad dan because like
you
and me he's from the great state of ohio
and i wanted that
connection and i wanted it to be
enjoyable after having
outside coverage like we have when you
know we're covering
the finals and all-star game back of the
worldwide leader of covering michael and
kobe shaquille of his height and
shaquille every day and then duane every
day
uh i wanted this so bad to be awesome
and it was it was he was present
he was great every single night he makes
everybody else
great every single night um i will say
this
i miss the 81 playoff game checks
that i got in those four years damn it
was 81
playoff games in four years that was
ridiculous
so uh that and uh and now i probably
would want to encourage him to do this
stan
i mean like there comes a point where
you know oh shave it all off you've got
to get
lebron james okay is he painting
how much is he painting his hairline on
there i
when you see a hairline it's painted dad
i mean it's not
like i don't know why i remember when he
was younger and i first brought it up
i said listen you have to do it in the
off seats you have to see
how your your hair looks you don't want
all this meat you know all bunched up
looking like a
a sack of hot dogs you want to make sure
you have
a nice tight melon i got a little little
something in the back but i'm you
talking about me behind my back next to
my face
but what if he has a scottie pippen head
man that's you gotta find out i said
that's the first thing you have to find
out if you look
good ball but what doesn't look good
is if you're out there with a whole
bunch of shellac
black
but if he was still there you wouldn't
be saying this it
every day i would just encourage him
that it is a good look
i have a senior in college a senior in
private high school you can make money
with no hair
[Laughter]
uh he's jason jackson the miami heat tv
host and uh just
remember i'm not here to cheer you i'm
here to
boo boo ya great to talk to you man
always thank you man jason jackson he's
one of the funniest guys i've ever been
around
he makes me laugh every time black
shellac
for lebron
i i was hoping that the heat would win a
game so i could have jason on
just for that reason